Now on to launching a cluster.
It's better to use
the advanced options so
you have more control over
the nodes in the cluster.
You can choose which applications
you want to install in the cluster.
Let's just stick with the Hadoop and
Hive for now.
You won't be doing any additional
configuration so skip this part.
But do read up on configuration in
the future as the default settings
such as the block size
might not fit your needs.
But do read up on the configuration in
the future as the default settings such
as the block size might
not fit your needs.
Here you can add the steps that
the cluster will run when it's created.
You can have the cluster
terminate itself after all
the steps are completed.
This is a convenient way to run
a bunch of analysis jobs without
having a permanent cluster.
For now, we'll leave this unchecked
since we want to keep the cluster around
for a bit.
Next, you can add nodes to the cluster.
The master node doesn't need
much computation power.
So this could be a smaller,
less expensive instance.
Amazon suggests you should
use M1.large instance.
The core nodes are used to store and
process data.
You need to create enough core
nodes to store your input data,
taking into account
the replication factor.
By default, replication factors three
for a cluster of ten or more nodes,
two for a cluster of four to nine nodes,
and one for a cluster with three or
fewer nodes.
For now, I’ll just choose two m3.xlarge
instances just the default setting.
Task nodes are used solely for
processing data.
You won’t use any now, so leave this
at 0 and continue with the setup.
You should point the login directory
to a folder on your s3 bucket then
continue on.
Finally, continue without a private key
or choose one you've used previously and
is still around on your computer.
You can use this key to SSH into
the cluster instances later.
Now create the cluster.
After a few minutes, it'll be ready.
You can add more core and
task nodes here by clicking Resize.
You run jobs on the cluster
by adding steps through here.
This is what you'll be doing next.